[Música]
ahora es en las regiones que los chefs
franceses con estrellas encuentran la
inspiración la búsqueda de productos
excepcionales es para ellos algo
ineludible en la alta gastronomía luego
sólo queda armonizar los sabores y darle
rienda suelta a la imaginación
[Música]
con ocasión de las fiestas de fin de año
edicta cocinero de renombre
que realiza una comida de dicha época
para nosotros su cupón cat del productor
al plato chef nos comparte la clave para
preparar sencillamente una comida 3
estrellas
cuando preparamos chalotas primero
echamos al así no se frita y se vuelven
como compota pero sobre todo queda
cuánto 13 minutos
para este menú especial es rica sublima
el pollo cada pedazo del pollo es usado
sin olvidar la osamenta que sirve para
preparar la salsa
y
un pequeño truco pero el que se está
quemando no quiero que se vuelva amargo
entonces desglosó con agua así
y ahora vuelvo reactivó la
caramelización lo hago tres veces así
concentro bien los sabores
el pecho del pollo se alza por todos los
lados antes de ser cocinado 14 minutos
en un horno a 140 grados
este pollo excepcional es criado en
buñol cerca del restaurante en la granja
la fusión
ah
[Música]
el chef para la visita con frecuencia
para aprovisionarse le puse los más
grandes perfecto 7 meses de crianza 27
meses de crianza el conocido cocinero
tal como dicta fue de 5 min ayer cambió
su gorro de cocinero a principios de los
años 2000 para dedicarse a la crianza de
pollos
este es el núcleo duro de la granja es
nuestro bien más valioso aquí los 1500
animales disponen de 5 hectáreas del
terreno 7 veces más espacio que un
criadero ecológico estas especies casi
que habían desaparecido
es un bello reproductor que agarre para
ustedes debe ser de unos 5 kilogramos es
una raza muy antigua de mil quinientos
mil quinientos cincuenta más o menos
[Aplausos]
esta granja es única en francia semillas
hábitat alimentación se optimiza todo
para generar una carne con una calidad
incomparable
te puse de la flecha también me gusta
con sus pequeños cuernos es un animal
bastante grande la diferencia con
barbies es que tiene una carne un poco
menos firme pero tiene mucho sabor
el plato es eso saber lo que se pone en
el plato del cliente es primordial hasta
pronto buena suerte buen servicio
gracias
[Aplausos]
en el restaurante los equipos hacen
pedidos para la continuación de la
receta
voy a llevarme dos bandejas de pamplinas
de aves dos manojos de mini sacrifice
cuatro zapatos grandes sí y veinte kilos
de remolacha roja cruda
las verduras frescas del restaurante de
erika son recolectadas a mano en esta
granja ecológica del gas especializada
en productos escasos y de calidad
80% de la actividad está dedicada a los
grandes restaurantes famosos o la
pamplina de las aves hay pimpinela que
crecen naturalmente en la tierra que
tiene sabor a pepino
estos productos no se encuentran en
ninguna otra parte la verde local hizo
uso aquí tiene o sales roja que tiene un
sabor un poco ácido como la grosella
este es el pedido de la melaza de esta
mañana que este pedido saldrá a la unah
20 pm para que lo reciba en la mañana
antes de las 11 m para que cuente con
ello en el servicio de mediodía
después del pollo es el turno de las
verduras
que están duras quiere decir que fueron
recogidas hace por otro
para acompañar el pollo el chef propone
un gratis de cardo y espinacas
x
una asociación original que permite
adaptar con elegancia una receta popular
de los sets de las recetas no muy
complicadas porque debe ser agradable
incluso los invitados hacerlos
participar es simpático entonces es así
como veo las cenas de las fiestas
gradín de cardo y espinacas
triffolio tuberos o
pollo en dos cocciones
y para terminar mermelada de limón
realizada con trufa de alba desde el
producto hasta el plato esta comida es
un concentrado de excelencia en cada
etapa
es